we mustn't be victims but protagonists
of our stories
i heard that you stalked steve mcqueen
for this role basically like i could not
stalk him
i'm kidding i'm kidding but you did
passionately want to get this role in
the minute you heard it announced
yeah again i didn't know specifically
what the role would be but i just knew
that he had something to do
with bringing caribbean culture to the
bbc i was like i wanna i wanna be
involved in that i don't care if i'm a
tree
i don't care if i'm the person going to
run off to get the the curry spice
i want to be involved so that was in
2015 and
and yeah here we are i mean it's really
incredible both like you and john
coming to it because i know you guys
both did like the same preparatory like
acting program and like now i like
really tell
these black british stories on such a
global audience and it's something like
that's universal over here in america
our stories don't get told so talk about
what it's like to bring
a story that maybe people know about but
they don't know in detail
oh man again you know you you would only
know about it if you were a part of that
community in notting hill and that time
it's not on a global scale but we're
pushing it out there right now which is
so great
it's great to be able to have this
opportunity to be represented your
culture being represented
within mainstream media you know steve
just being bold and and just being man
enough to
to stand by his word and say you know
this is in his heart this isn't his
heart
15 years ago and to see it through right
to the end
is beautiful so it's a treat to come to
work and see people that you connect
with had share the same culture as you
you know it's just just a beautiful
treat and just proud that this is now
being broadcasted to the world
what's really incredible too is it's not
just one story it's several chapters and
it really
gives an in-depth um sort of like
narration of this particular community
throughout the time period that they
were not seeing but in doing so
you're playing real-life people and
that's like daunting as well as i would
assume very invigorating but what was it
like paint playing homage
the real life woman that you're
portraying and how difficult was it to
balance
again that was like you're constantly
thinking about the script and
thinking about the words that you have
to say and the scenes that you have to
do and
constantly checking in with steve to be
like are you sure affiliate will say
something like this you know um
because you want her to be proud you
want her to feel like
you know you correctly represented her
because his story is
now taking the forefront um to be
you know showcased so you carry that
it's a little bit of nerves when you
carry that
it's great because you're not just
having one story
being told and pushed to the forefront
you're getting several different stories
um that you didn't know about so it's
it's just something fresh is something
new you know for us right now in 2020
but
you know these are stories that were
buried and hidden for years so
you know it's important it's important
that we share it
these are new types of human beings of
the entire sort of small
acts um anthology yours is the only one
that's based off of like a completely
fictional story and dance and music is
just such a huge part of it i was just
curious
was that daunting for you guys as the
cast to know you guys got to pull off
these amazing dance numbers
definitely at first i think it was more
of the fact that it wasn't based on a
true story that we were quite like oh
gosh you know but um afterwards when we
understood it and we understood that
this episode is an escape
from the the frustrations from watching
the other films because i myself haven't
had the chance to see them yet but i
know what they are about
and um you know i can imagine they're
very hard-hitting
so it's almost as if our episode is a
house party in itself
and has been able to escape yeah i also
think it's
even though it's not based on a true
story there is still people's truths you
know i spoke a lot to my mom
um and my dad and these are their it's
still relatable it's still their truths
um and there's gonna be so many
different moments that people go oh my
gosh
oh yeah i know my dad watching it and
something as small as the guy is banging
against the wall in the party and my dad
was like yes yes yes you know
so it will still definitely relate
yeah and big ups to you know steve um
and the entire like production team
because
one thing i know is like i wasn't living
in the 70s but i
live for that time period and although
it was like a huge like 60s and 70s huge
point of unrest it also
provided some of the most incredible
like music and dance and steve like
lived in that so talk about him really
sort of
immersing you guys in this world and
then also like how it was just working
with him because i know he's a director
that gets
great performances from his actors oh
he's incredible um
definitely so r1 is the early 80s
and with steve he's so open and trusting
of his actors
um to bring what they have to the table
we also worked with an incredible
choreographer called coral
and her thing was she got the supporting
artists for example before we started
filming she got them in a room she said
it's not enough to just have them in
costume i need to play some music i need
them to understand this energy that
needs to be had for this film
they need to know it um so i think even
just doing that
just it was like there was no to me
there was we were all together it's not
about leads or supporting everyone was
just together and as a whole in that
and then she got us proper on the
dancing to understand
how different the dancing was back then
and to understand that it's heavy in
your feet and it's grounded and you're
connected to the earth
um and i think that is obviously why
steve
asked coral to come and step in because
he really wanted us to understand it's
not just about just dancing to dance
it means so much more it's again people
releasing their frustrations
letting things out feeling it in their
body it was so beautiful to be able to
experience that
yeah and like you said yours is the only
one that's that's not based off of
history but it still hits within the
whole vibe of the anthology over several
decades this idea
of beauty and art in the midst of
social and political unrest and although
yours leans more in the entertainment
and the things that people did to escape
all of the other stuff is like so still
there and a part of it
and i'm actually curious though since it
is more centered in on the dance stuff
if you have a particular moment from a
dance movie
besides yours like say
like because i like i always think to
like that she's all that dance moment
like that's just like a random dance
moment in a teen movie but i love it i
wonder if you have one of those that you
particularly love
mine would be the dance the the dance in
death proof have you watched death proof
by
quentin tarantino dance like
um that's who i would i love tarantino
and i love
that dance has always stayed with me
they are leaders
but are rooted deep among those they
lead playing real people there's always
like um
a legacy and a lot of homage you have to
pay to these real-life
historical figures but then also try to
tell a compelling story so i'll start
with you
and the malachi if y'all can talk about
portraying these real life characters
and how you approached it
well fortunately you know um i went to
drama college what does that mean i know
so it's a weird place
to answer this question but actually
it's not because i did went to drama
college so what does that mean well
we were taught a method of being able to
access
ways and means to to explore uh
different energies
and psychological mathematics when it
comes to portraying whatever it is that
is portrayed in the mangrove
uh in frank specifically so you know
what do we know we know that this is a
historical thing we also know that this
is not a pain that is unique
frank is not the first and last person
to to
essentially suffer abuse as a result of
the color of his skin so we know that
it seems to be an ancestral
cry um or something maybe not an
ancestral cry but it
it it's about that feeling is about so
we know that
daunting yes because you got to take it
seriously but fortunately you know we
were built for that we're actors
it's it's it's not that it's no biggie
it is a biggie
uh in having to play these roles but
fortunately we went to these places and
we've studied life enough and we've
studied human nature enough
to be able to when someone's like anger
pain frustration abuse
as the result of certain
factors go um
fortunately we've got a lot of that
stuff in the back pocket already right
all of us you malachi our parents like
you know
so that's you know not easy but that's
that's
uh help useful um
and then what you have is the idea that
says yeah but this is in a
this is this is not now this is then
and what does that mean it's the same
[ __ ] sorry
you know but it is i see this
it's the same uh you know
it's that isn't it yeah there's it's
problems throughout the diaspora
and then malachi if you can go ahead and
talk about you know again playing the
real person too
yeah i mean for me um you know you have
some other characters in the mangrove
nine that
weren't didn't have i guess i don't want
to use the word fame but dark is how was
known you know he had a he had a tv show
he was a he was
he was actually involved politically um
like he was
he was a known face and so there is a
lot more documents on him there's a lot
more videos
on him you know where you can actually
see him speaking and expressing himself
and so
for that you know there's one thing
playing a real person and there's
another thing playing a real person that
is known to a community already
and so there was a there was a weight
behind it even though i knew very little
about
darkest um at first there was a way to
kind of get this
right um as there would be for every
character to be honest but more so
for him i guess um because he
like i said my mom knows who he he was
you know he grew up watching him on tv
um and then
you have to remember as sean saying that
you're an artist you know so you know
he is a person that existed but so
should every character that you play you
should approach them in the same way of
like bringing
a truth and a light to this person that
was previously unknown
or at least unknown in part um and
telling their story so it was approached
in the same way